good morning John it's Friday November 7
almost three years ago you and I decided
to do something that was really hard but
that we really wanted to do eventually
with a lot of help crash course became a
thing and a lot of teachers and a lot of
students use it we've kept it free it's
available for anyone with an internet
connection and it is and I say this with
a deep love for the Pemberley digital
stuff and Sasha and VidCon and the
Wimbley wadley's the best thing that we
do it is the thing that I am very proud
of and so with the tear in my eye
here's a look back at the last three
years of crash course hi I'm John Green
this is crash course world history and
today we're going to talk about
civilization I'm Hank green and I want
to teach you chemistry but please do not
run away screen people may not be the
easiest organisms to understand but
you're a person right oh god fan it's me
from college me from the past has become
me from college this is a disaster
nothing escapes the long arm of ecology
like any good 50 cent song biology is
just about sex and not die the test will
last your entire life and it will be
comprised of the millions of decisions
that when taken together make your life
yours and everything everything will be
on
the only reason crash course works is
because people like it most of the
people who watch crash course do it
because they want to not because they
have to the first two years of crash
course it was funded by a Google grant
basically and that Google money ran out
and we had to figure out how to keep
making this show so basically we just
asked as people who like crash course if
they'd like to give a little bit of
money so that it could keep existing for
them and also for all of the other
people in the world we didn't want to
start charging for it we didn't want to
put it on exclusive platform where only
people using that platform could get it
got a lot of offers to do those sorts of
things and to make fair amounts of money
doing it we didn't want to lock the
content down but it looks like we might
have had to but people decided to just
give us money through subbable crash
course relies hugely on that support and
I could never be more grateful for it
means we get to keep making better and
more content we've also done some
partnerships the big history series that
we're in the middle of right now is in
partnership with the Bill Gates
think-tank BGC 3 and now we're working
on a significantly larger relationship
with PBS Digital Studios second I'll
allow us to basically double the amount
of content that we're doing on crash
course of course PBS just like crash
course is largely funded by people who
watch and love PBS stuff so it's sort of
a natural fit so we worked with these
people before we like them we work with
them on Frankenstein MD in the art
assignment so in 2015 we are hopefully
going to be doing four crash courses
Craig benzine aka wheezy waiter will be
doing a government class he'll plate who
is probably the most successful
astronomy blogger in the world will be
doing crash course astronomy hi we'll be
doing crash course physiology and we're
still working on it but hopefully we
will also be doing crash course
economics if you haven't checked out
crash course yet there's a ton of really
interesting content history in biology
and chemistry and ecology and literature
and soon government and astronomy and
physiology and economics economics they
really do say economics economics is
what I meant to say PBS Digital Studios
does a ton of really interesting stuff
as well there's a link to their channel
in the description and finally unrelated
to any of this I have an announcement to
make John and I starting Monday will be
doing at the 12 days of pizza mess
during those 12 days John and I will
make a video every day except for the
weekend just like brother who 2.0
there's gonna be a lot of log brothers
content coming at you so be ready I'm
doing Monday Wednesday Friday next week
and then Tuesday Thursday the week after
that so you gonna see a lot of paper
town set videos are gonna decrease in
quality because we're gonna have to make
so many of them we're probably gonna go
a little bit insane it's gonna be great
I'm actually really looking forward to
it I feel like it's getting back to my
roots you know I want a little bit more
back and forth I want to feel more
connected to it on so this is gonna be a
good two weeks peeps and this begins on
Monday so I'm gonna make two videos in a
row so John I'll see you on Tuesday and
you will see me on Monday
[Music]